you know what's funny when there's not
that many changes it really puts a
magnifying glass on the few changes that
there actually are
have you ever listened to a car reviewer
describe the latest generation Porsche
911 like this is a car that's looked
more or less the same for the past 50
years with slight Evolutions with each
new generation and literally every time
you watch or read a review they always
say every single time oh it's so refined
oh this is an engineering Masterpiece
that's been perfected over Generations
it's a formula that's been developed in
the same direction for years I actually
as a kid I used to actively dislike
Porsches because I just I knew they were
expensive but I thought they're all so
boring they all look like the same thing
why would you get one of those when you
could get a way more exciting Ferrari or
McLaren instead
but as I've gotten older I I can
appreciate the Porsche formula a little
more I don't love it or anything I
wouldn't say I love it but I can
appreciate it more
does that make sense I hope that makes
sense
[Music]
foreign
this is the iPhone 15.
Pro
not
a lot of changes
so okay I think people got to get this
thought out of their head that you've
got to upgrade every year to the newest
phone like I realized most of us already
know this but for some reason people are
still stuck on this thing where they say
oh last year's phone is is barely
different from this year's phone it's
not worth upgrading but like that's not
new like the Zenfone 10 I just reviewed
is just a refinement of the Zenfone 9
like the bleeding edge Rog phone has
looked the same for three years now the
pixel is finding its stride with design
but what we're really looking for is for
them to fix anything that's wrong or bad
and then just find ways clever ways good
interesting ways to just get a little
bit better every year so that over a
long time over a bunch of improvements
it adds up to a bigger more significant
change so that's what's happening here
with this iPhone 15 Pro I've been using
it for about two weeks now they've made
some improvements but now we're starting
to also see some possible problems some
new issues that have risen up so uh
let's talk about it so there's basically
four new features they've added here I'm
gonna go over some of the more
fundamental and existential stuff in the
regular iPhone 15 review so definitely
make sure you're subscribed to see that
when it comes out but for the pro it's
time to Deep dive on the stuff that's
unique to this one the uh professional
stuff that being the build the chip the
cameras and the action button so easiest
place to start is the way they've built
this phone so Apple made an update to
the build and the materials of the
iPhone this year they've softened the
corners a little bit it's clearly still
a boxy design but you know now instead
of a completely flat glass at the front
there's this gentle little curve just at
the very edges I think that'll maybe
make screen protectors slightly more
intricate but I think it has a nice look
to it and then the screen sizes are
exactly the same but now the bezels are
actually a tiny bit Slimmer all the way
around so technically the phone is like
one millimeter smaller diagonally and
the rails have famously switched from
that shiny stainless steel to a lighter
coated and brushed titanium the result
it's very slightly better I think it's
fun it's kind of funny I've always
Associated a heavy phone with like
expensive feeling you know like the
ceramic phones are like extra heavy they
feel like substance but I understand why
people want it to be lighter and so this
phone is actually noticeably lighter
than the previous Pro it's it's 10 on
paper but it feels like more than 10 and
then there's a new set of colors too so
I'm sticking with it this new natural
titanium is the best color this is the
first year I am not ordering a dark or
black iPhone they still look good don't
get me wrong but they get all kinds of
fingerprints on them like crazy and also
my worries about the light colored
scratches if you go deep enough we're
all confirmed by Zach j-rig everything
in his video cutting the thing up so
because I'm on team no case I'm going
with the all gray phone I think it looks
dope so I'm going with that I think
basically the idea is if if you have a
perfectly working phone there's no world
where you should upgrade to this one
just for the titanium build or just for
the slightly thinner bezels but you have
to appreciate put this up next to an
iPhone 11 then yeah you can see the
differences compounding over time just
like if you sat in a 992 generation 911
right now after sitting in a 997
generation car but the real highlight of
this build here let's be honest is uh
there's a new Port at the bottom that
USB type c which makes a big difference
to people like me who have other Gadgets
in their life computers headphones mouse
keyboard I just bring one charger it
works with everything I have already had
this rite of passage moment that
everyone who gets this phone is going to
have where you have an existing
lightning cable and you try to plug it
in and then you're like oh right new
cable but now I've gotten used to it but
the thing is I could I could have sworn
Apple would do more with this port like
okay we know that they're basically
forced into doing this by the EU so
shout out to the EU for that now I have
a USB iPhone but like the only pitch is
just hey one cable for everything
that's it Apple really so like with 30
pin to lightning all those years ago the
benefit was obvious it's just so much
smaller of a port so that let them fit
more stuff in the phone plus it's
reversible now with this USB type c it's
like okay it was already small it was
already reversible charging speed did
not improve at all it's still 25 watts
there's no extra like desktop mode plug
it into a monitor and get there's no
decks or anything like that right it's
just
one cable for everything
okay fine sure welcome to the club you
know iPhone users can now take advantage
of the you in USBC I talked about the
handshake it does with plugging directly
into other phones and reverse charging
them at four and a half watts in the
unboxing video that's pretty neat you
can also plug in other things plug in a
keyboard and type with it plug in a
monitor it'll mirror your screen at up
to 4K 60. and the profile now supports
USB 3.0 data transfer speeds so you can
get that prores footage off the phone
noticeably faster and you can actually
for the first time shoot video directly
onto an external drive now there's some
talk about the cable that comes in the
Box remember that nice high quality
braided USBC cable that comes in the Box
but it's only USB 2.0 transfer speeds
it's a slow cable so if you have a pro
phone you need to get a faster separate
cable for it that seemed weird to people
but it's not that's very normal most
smartphones come with just a USBC cable
just to charge it's a charging cable if
you wanted a data cable you'd have to
buy a thicker more robust cable that
looks the same
but as a data cable it's kind of
confusing and annoying actually welcome
to the world of USBC my friends
it's good to have you but that is a good
segue to the main enabler the new
Powerhouse chip inside this phone with a
new name the a17 pro so the base iPhone
15s got last year's a16 bionic from the
14 pro and so here's this new more
powerful chip in the highest end phones
and it's not The a17 Bionic this is the
first one with the pro Name a17 Pro and
this thing goes kind of crazy on paper
this is their first three nanometer chip
actually the first three nanometer chip
in any phone that we'll probably see for
at least another year or two I ran some
benchmarks it's literally approaching M1
chip levels of synthetic benchmark
scores now compared to last year it's 10
to 20 percent more powerful on both the
CPU and the GPU which is very
respectable but more power is like more
horsepower in a car it's only really
useful or noticeable if it lets you do
more things with it I'm going to live in
this analogy a bit more for a minute but
like the last generation Porsche 911
Turbo S it was already so ballistic fast
that you never approach that limit
anywhere on public streets until you get
to the highest end of performance on the
track and the highest end iPhone is the
same way like the pro iPhone's been
great at just surfing Instagram and
texting and doing all the normal web
browsing basic stuff you do on a phone
and so the only place you'd really
notice the extra performance is
well we got a gaming demo Apple showed
these wild demos on the new iPhone at
the keynote and uh just a disclaimer I'm
not much of a phone gamer so I'll defer
the commentary on this to dave2d you can
go watch his video link below but they
literally launched exclusive games on
the iPhone that are like Resident Evil
Village and Assassin's Creed but not on
Cut Down mobile versions these are
literally the same versions with the
same assets and same textures and
everything from the PlayStation version
because it literally is the PlayStation
version that's impressive plus you know
performance Headroom is never a bad
thing but I think also for me and for a
lot of other people the more impactful
things that you'll actually notice about
this new chip are in the dedicated parts
of it that are for specific tasks like
the new image signal processor lets you
take really really fast lag free photos
constantly the new neural engine
recognizes portrait mode subjects like
people's faces and dogs and cats
automatically and lets you go back in
time and set a regular photo to a
portrait mode photo the USB 3 controller
that enables faster data transfer speeds
is also on the a17 pro all of that is
coming from the new chip but what I'm
more concerned with at the moment is
battery life okay so actually it's kind
of two main issues that have been
popping up that you kind of have to try
to figure out are they isolated issues
are these real problems with the phone
and those are battery life and
overheating issues and to be honest part
of the reason this review took like
longer than normal is I've had I've been
really trying to dig into the battery
and figure out what's going on here so
objectively speaking these phones have
slightly bigger batteries than last year
and a new three nanometer chip so in a
controlled environment they should do
better and they do they literally last
longer on like simple Benchmark stuff so
that's good news now when I test a phone
like normal I pretty much I kind of go
by feel I always have some mix of good
days some average days and then some bad
days where I can sort of figure out
what's draining it what its weaknesses
are and I can come to a conclusion from
that so now here we are I get a couple
days in I get a couple weeks in and I've
had a good amount of average days I've
had a couple of those bad draining days
but I also haven't had any of those
amazing days where I got like nine hours
of screen on time I just haven't had any
yet and then we also started to see some
of those headlines about battery life
potentially being worse and there's also
some overheating issues popping up on
Twitter or X and some people were asking
if mine has had any issues so here's the
weird answer yes but not what I would
expect I was two days ago literally I
was just at a golf tournament it was in
Florida it was like a 100 degree real
feel something crazy like that and I'm
outside with my phone at Max brightness
with GPS going all day out in the sun
and it was fine no problem no
overheating issues but then a couple
hours later I'm on the airplane with my
phone in airplane mode and I've got just
like music playing on Bluetooth with
Spotify and like scrolling through
Instagram and
for like five minutes the phone just
gets really hot and just blasts through
like five percent battery and then it's
fine again afterwards and I'm like there
there almost seems to be no Rhyme or
Reason why it does this randomly once in
a while so my best theory is that the
a17 pro is just it's a more powerful
chip and so therefore is able to drain
power more quickly than before in high
intensity settings like gaming Etc and
there's also been some issues attributed
to iOS 17 bugs like we're already on
17.0.2 I imagine there's some more
updates coming to both iOS and a bunch
of apps but by the end of this I kind of
feel like I'm expecting battery life to
basically even out to be the same as
last year which is a boring answer but
that's kind of what I expect now we can
talk all we want about what the word Pro
actually means in a smartphone but with
iPhones that is mostly meant cameras and
uh it turns out there is a lot going on
with these relatively similar looking
cameras on these new Pro phones both in
hardware and software so you're looking
at a new bigger 48 megapixel main camera
there's also an improved Ultra wide with
a closer up macro capability and a whole
telephoto situation and that will get to
in a minute but then with software there
is this whole new intricate image
processing pipeline happening so you
know how most smartphones a lot of them
today have like 48 megapixel cameras and
they all bend down to 12 megapixels they
give you 12 megapixel shots you know
previous iPhones did this
um this new one for those who might have
missed it is actually by default
spitting out 24 megapixel images
instead of 12. and it's only about one
and a half times the file size so this
new process which is the same actually
across the board for iPhone 15s and 15
Pros is it's taking a 48 megapixel full
sensor shot for detail information and
also taking a full sensor 12 megapixel
shot which is the quad binning for light
information and noise and then it's
using the neural net to combine them and
do a sort of a detail transfer to get
you this hybrid 24 megapixel image it's
very complicated very clever
and the end result is
slightly better it's really right in
line with what I've been saying so if
you just generally look at photos shot
on this camera it's it's an iPhone photo
like they look pretty great they're
awesome with dynamic range and sharpness
across the board I still prefer and
shoot in the rich contrast profile most
of the time but yeah mostly the iPhone
is one of the best cameras at just
pointing and shooting in full auto just
getting results that look good even if
it doesn't look the most like real life
you know it's doing the classic
re-lighting and tone mapping and
everything we're used to from all this
smart HDR it's all here and a lot of
people like it and it looks good uh the
improved macro mode is also really good
and with this natural fall off with the
primary camera without even needing
portrait mode you can get some blurred
backgrounds it's awesome autofocus is
also really really fast especially
whenever there's a face in the scene
this thing loves seeing faces and the
benefit of the bigger sensor shows
itself at night too with even longer
handheld captures it's not magic it's
just physics but you know does the 24
megapixel make a difference over the 12
megapixel well zoomed out absolutely not
they look basically the same so you got
to zoom in and even at 50 Zoom you still
can't really tell it's not until you
zoom all the way in that you can okay
you can see a difference you can start
to notice a difference in fine detail
and contrast the 15 Pro is definitely
one you're pixel peeping more contrasty
and sharp when you're all the way zoomed
in versus last year but that's just when
you've zoomed all the way in and by the
way once you get past 2x Zoom it's back
to kicking out regular 12 megapixel
images so again this is it's like it's a
small small year-over-year improvement
with that tiny amount of like pixel
peeping detail but over a longer
distance over a bunch of generations
that's the type of thing that adds up
they even on the pro phones did a couple
of presets from the 1X lens there's a 24
millimeter all the way zoomed out then a
28 millimeter a little bit tighter and a
35 millimeter that all have their own
dedicated image processing pipeline
press sets to maximize detail into these
basically super res Zoom focal lengths
that you can digitally Zoom between I
wouldn't exactly call it having extra
lenses on the phone but you know 1.5 x
zoom on last year's phone versus 1.5 x
zoom on this year's phone slight
difference but there is a difference
honestly the most Pro things about these
new phones though is definitely their
video cameras so I'm just going to nerd
out about these for a second because the
iPhone's video capabilities I've talked
about this so much but they are still so
clearly far out in front of the rest of
the smartphone World it doesn't even
shoot 8K which is it's totally capable
of with the 48 megapixels I wish they
would let us but even just at 4K 30 in
full auto the detail the autofocus the
slight depth the dynamic range the
stabilization they're all world class I
mean if you want to just look at test
footage the entire electric rivian
delivery van review I did on the
autofocus channel was shot on iPhone 15
Pro Audio included I'll drop the link
below if you want to watch that whole
thing also shout out to the New av1
Codex support on the chip that's going
to play nice with YouTube but this year
you can also shoot log literally a pro
camera feature now it is annoyingly
buried several layers deep in the
separate Settings app which is really
not very Pro but if you find the time to
go switch over there and get into log
the iPhone will shoot with way more
information that classic flat log look
dynamic range everything and you don't
have to deal with whatever Apple was
going to do with over sharpening and
saturation and processing Apple has its
own transformation Lut to turn it into
SDR or HDR or you can go in and fully
grade it yourself to really get the most
out of the iPhone's video and it looks
really like really really good so the
one thing that I'm going to say to you
know because I'm pixel peeping at this
point is the haloing from point light
sources you know it's one of the hardest
challenges with these tiny Optics so I
get why they haven't just fixed it yet
but like it's pretty bad anytime there's
any sort of Point lights especially with
video despite whatever new lens coating
they're doing it's pretty dramatic and
it seems like it's the worst on the
iPhone of any other phone so it's there
gonna point it out again but hey if
that's the biggest downside of iPhone
video I'll definitely take it and then
iPhone 15 Pro Max the big one is the
only one that comes with the new 5x
larger telephoto lens uh I would bet my
life that that's going to come down to
the smaller 16 Pro next year whatever
but it's only the big one this time but
yeah it does let you get a little
further with Max Zoom from 15x to 25x
it's nice if you do a lot of Zoom photos
and videos which is a very specific
crowd there's some people that do that
you know concert goers things like that
but there are just very few people who
should buy one just for this lens
because it also means you have to have a
bigger phone and it also happens to mean
that your 4X photos just before you get
to 5x will actually be worse on this
phone but yeah it's not nearly as
capable as some of the longer telephoto
periscope soap lens I mean Samsung has a
10x Optical lens that blows this one out
the water in terms of reach I think
Apple's main advantage really is just
stabilization like they finally do that
zoom in preview window on the corner of
the viewfinder and they over stabilize
the frame so you can zoom all the way in
and get a shot in super creeper mode
it's it's great but I'm just going to
shamelessly borrow a line from Mr mobile
because he said it as well as anyone
possibly could and he's right which is
just that so much of the differences
between these cameras this one the last
iphone the Samsungs the pixels of the
world so much of the difference between
them is software that is hardly even
consistent anymore so if you are looking
for like a hard verdict on like iPhone
15 Pro side by side versus Samsung
versus pixel or Oppo or whatever else
you kind of just have to make it up
after a while like yeah there are going
to be certain instances like exact Zoom
focal lengths where one is sharper than
the other but honestly at the end of the
day a lot of it is going to be taste and
so yeah yeah you just kind of have to
figure out which one you like as far as
image quality and especially UI just the
actual way you shoot photos and videos
which reminds me I do want to mention
this raw Max button is hilarious this is
this is a button to to take your full
res 48 megapixel Pro Raw photos but it
just says raw Max okay and if you want a
48 megapixel jpeg you have to jump back
into the settings app switch it over
then bounce back and now the button says
jpeg Max which is also hilarious
last thing I gotta say though this new
Pro phone has an action button on this
new Pro iPhone only because only pros
need customization look I
kind of love the action button but I
also need to realize that it's it's it's
kind of either overrated or underrated
depending on who you are like on one
hand it's literally a customizable
button like who even saw this coming it
replaces the least used button that was
on previous iPhones because your phone
should always be on mute anyway and so
then you can map this action button to
basically anything you want you can keep
it as a mute switch and it has the same
strong haptics so you can tell if it's
muted or unmuted in your pocket without
looking but there's also a bunch of
other cool functions you can pick from
from launching your camera to a voice
recorder to just literally any app on
your phone you want through a Siri
shortcut your favorite YouTube channel
right now is probably making a tutorial
on the best series shortcuts to map to
the action button from launching apps to
to the specific things inside of apps
from unlocking your car to not just
launching my favorite task manager app
but launching a new task inside of of my
task manager app it just lets me it's
great it's awesome honestly I hope it
gets copied even though a bunch of
phones were doing this years ago and
then they stopped I hope they bring it
back now in response to how great this
is but on the other hand
I I do kind of feel like for a lot of
people this is gonna be one of those
things that they play with for like a
three or four days and then just kind of
forget about it and never use it again
and I mostly think that's because it's
not super reachable like it's not a
one-handable button where your fingers
usually rest for everyone especially on
the pro Max it's way up there in the
corner above the volume buttons it could
be a cool shutter button for the camera
but the volume buttons already do that
so yeah I feel like you might as well
just end up setting it back to a mute
switch and forgetting about it after a
few weeks but I guess that's fine too
it's one of those things that you'll
just figure out which user you are after
you use it for a while kind of like I've
been using the new that eight Sleep
mattress cover that I was talking about
I've been using it for about three
months now this is the Pod cover that
goes on your mattress that either warms
you up or cools you down helps you sleep
like now that I've used it for a while
I've understood like I was a skeptic at
first but honestly this is one of those
things where I go to a hotel bed and I
have a harder time sleeping which it
used to be the other way around but I
just sleep so much better in the eight
sleep bed because it's cooled down to
let you get to sleep early and then
warms up in the morning to help you wake
up and it's become really clear that
temperature is one of the most important
factors when it comes to sleep and it's
become real obvious to me that falling
asleep faster getting better quality
sleep and then being able to depend on
it is something I wouldn't trade for
anything it's just it took me some time
to learn that plus there's an app that
shows me all my info about my sleep
every night and it lets me adjust the
autopilot if I want if your partner
sleeps at a different side on the same
bed they can adjust the temperature in
the app too it's great so I'll leave a
link to it below and since they're a
great sponsor they're actually giving
you guys 200 off the Pod cover if you
use code MKBHD at eightsleep.com
MKBHD but anyway what's the verdict
what's the what's the verdict with the
new Pro iPhone of 2023.
is one of those things where like I have
conversations with friends and I always
end up having to try to condense it all
and summarize it into like one sentence
and the truth is like it's the same
phone as last year with USB a little bit
of a faster chip a little bit of a
brighter screen a little bit of thinner
bezels and like
I don't know better cameras that's kind
of it so you have to decide how much of
that is important to you are any of
those things important to you
honestly USB
might be the most important thing
about the new iPhone
despite what Apple was hoping
welcome to the club my friends
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
foreign